All right.
Welcome back to Computer Vision.
If I'm a little less energetic than
usual I just flew back from Taiwan and
boy are my arms tired.
That's like a really,
really, really, really old joke but
I really did just fly back from Taiwan.
After spending just four days there and
back.
So if I start talking,
if I start talking quietly,
Megan'll remind me to wake up a little.
All right, today and for
the next little bit,
we're going to be talking
about segmentation.
And it's going to follow our
color conversation because
it's important to think about spaces in
which you're describing your pixels and
doing that and
the fact that you guys now know about
color spaces will make this easier.